mission impossible in the stash heard
around the world
legit sexy stash gonna be real mission
impossible fallout 2 mission impossible
fallout is the sixth Mission Impossible
movie in the mission impossible
franchise that's 22 years I believe six
movies one lead actor never changed uh
no reboot so that's pretty impressive by
Hollywood standards Homme Cruise is back
as Ethan Hunt you have Simon Pegg ving
rhames they usual crew they got to find
these nukes because it's it's always new
it's a little sneaks but there's a lot
going on also a lot going on they're not
gonna spoil so let's just kind of get
into what I like first of all Tom Cruise
I feel like this is repetitive every
time I'm like he's still got it but he
does it dude dangles from a helicopter
it's like he was like idled from a plane
I don't know if I can outdo that but
let's dangle me from a helicopter
next time we'll probably be a rocket
because why not and Henry Cavill I
thought Tom Cruise and Henry Cavill they
brought some good rivalry it was a good
dynamic between them I like the fact
this movie has humor interjected into it
you see some action movies these days
they just they overplay the humor cards
sometimes I don't feel this movie
overplayed his hand at humor I felt
having humor in these moments which is
very reasonable very human very normal
very real but really this is not only an
espionage movie not only a spy movie
it's an action movie and holy [ __ ] the
action there's a common phrase when
people are reviewing action movies is
like yes you know it's it's a fun time
at the movies it's just it's fun it's
meant to be fun it's like this movie
gets that but also doesn't compromise
everything else in the process whereas I
feel a lot of movies that go for that a
lot of movies that want to be like you
know we're gonna be the fun action movie
they compromised a lot in the process in
terms of character and depth you can't
take the movie seriously because it
doesn't take itself seriously this is on
this fine because we all know whether
therefore they know the movie they're
making we know the movie we're watching
but it's also really refreshing on those
rare occasions to find a movie that
excels in the action movie Department
but also takes itself seriously enough
for you to see a genuine attempt at
someone making the best movie of the
summer I really feel like this movie's
gonna make other action movies up there
games like all the other movies gonna be
like oh god you mean we can have action
that's that good and also have a movie
that is by and large that good if it's
not an entertaining foot chase sequence
it's an entertaining car chase sequence
if it's not an entertaining car chase
sequence it's an entertaining
motorcycles that
etc there's more it's like the movie
goes enough for you to white-knuckle it
and then keeps you there for a second
and then goes one step further before
you pass out in the movies like don't
worry we're gonna let you breathe after
this last thing and you just have to
hold your breath a little more it's like
you're trying to make audiences around
the world just simultaneously pass out
from tension this movie soars as high as
possible without actually burning its
own wings we can say mission impossible
follow I'm trying to look for flaws
because this is a review I feel like I'm
supposed to have plus I just can't think
of any it's an epic it's a true
espionage spy action movie epic it's
what two hours twenty minutes long I
wanted it to go for longer it's like no
don't stop now because throughout the
movie they do this thing and they have
to go on to the next thing they finish
that thing they have to go on to the
next thing and when the last thing
happens the last thing is obviously the
last thing but I was like I could take
one more thing no okay and credits I
suppose I could have played up the
conflict between Ethan Hunt and another
character in the movie in the trailer
you see her say don't make me go through
you I could have played it up more than
they ended up playing it up in the movie
but it doesn't compromise movie as a
whole that's like an else world
hypothesis that I'm throwing out there
in the end Mission Impossible fallout it
had it it had it for me it had more than
I thought it could none of that
shaky-cam nonsense that makes you
nauseous you get nauseous is because
you're holding your breath too long
because the movies intense they were six
movies deep in the mission impossible
franchise and they're making their best
stuff now I haven't had an adrenaline
rush like that in the theater in years
and I will say mission impossible
fallout is awesome tacular
we're ISO Mission Impossible fall out
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite and
least favorite Mission Impossible movies
whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]